Nicaragua y el Vaticano en crisis
primeras informaciones aseguraban que el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega había roto sus
relaciones diplomáticas con la santa
sede desde el Ministerio de exteriores
nicaragüense lo calificaron de noticia
falsa y precisaron el gobierno de
Reconciliación y unidad nacional de
nuestra Nicaragua bendita y siempre
libre precisa que entre el estado
Vaticano y la República de Nicaragua se
ha planteado una suspensión de las
relaciones diplomáticas
pese a ser la institución con mayor
aprobación del país la Iglesia Católica
está siendo perseguida por el gobierno
de Ortega una escena de eclesiásticos
llegaron a ser apresados otros han sido
desterrados y la semana santa prohibida
entre los 222 excarcelados políticos
expulsados a Estados Unidos no estuvo
monseñor Rolando Álvarez quien se negó a
viajar con el resto le condenaron a 26
años de cárcel esto ha enfadado al Papa
Francisco
yo ahí con mucho respeto
no me queda otra que pensar en un
desequilibrio
de la persona que dirige
fuera de lo que estamos viviendo es como
si fuera a traer
de dictaduras
del 17 comunistas o hitlerianas del 35
están las aquí las mismas
no tipo de dictaduras
groseras
días antes Ortega había dicho que los
curas los obispos y los papás son una
mafia mientras que hace un año Nicaragua
ya había expulsado al nuncio papal
Valdemar estánislav